bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 weekend
sorti idé loisirs activités culturelles
nous en parlons tous les vendredis et
nous recevons tout de suite Syvie launa
bonsoir directrice divine tourisme pour
une rubrique maintenant bien connue une
rubrique qui se déroule tous les 15
jours et vous parcourez le le
département pour nous donner des idées
alors c'est le printemps j'ai envie de
dire on a si Syvie c'est le printemps on
a envie de mettre le nez dehors pas ce
weekend les weekend prochain et pourquoi
pas partir à LAAC cuueillette de
produits frais à la découverte de
boutique gourmande vous avez fait un
petit tour d'horizon dans le département
y nous avons plein de produits locaux
même si c'est pas si évident en région
Île-de-France d'y penser et bien il y en
a plein et on va commencer par la ferme
de enfin les fermes de Gali puis qu'il y
en a deux il y en a une à saint-ciiier
l'école et une à Sartrouville et là on
prend sa petite brouette ces petites
barquettes ces petits sacs et on va
accueillir dans les allées au grand A
quand il fait beau bien sûr et puis on
peut acheter aussi des des produits euh
et également pour les enfants pratiquer
des activités des
ateliers toujours découvrir les animaux
et tout plein de choses pour un bon
weekend en perspective voilà ça c'est la
ferme de Gal on connaitt plus celle de
saint-cer l'école que celle de de
sartrouille mais c'est à découvrir on va
du côté maintenant de la ferme du loger
à jumoville oui alors jumoville c'est un
petit peu plus loin c'est tout petit
hein c'est une commune qui est toute
petite à peu près au centre du du
département petite commune rurale et là
ben en ce moment c'est les asperges
vertes alors si vous si vous aimez ça
effectivement c'est là c'est c'est le
moment où il allit on peut aussi
cueillir des des fleurs des tulipe
notamment et puis la spécialité de cette
ferme du logis c'est aussi de de
fabriquer des
confitures et des sorbets et des pâtes
de fruits donc av vis au gourmand oui
pâtes de fruit c'est bon oui une autre
ferme il y en a plein des
fermespartement est très rural cette
fois du côté de saintnon la bot et la
ferme du Clos d'enign c'est ça al je
découvre tout là avec
vous vous découvrez en même temps le le
département en même temps que les fermes
alors c'est effectivement un espace où
on peut cueillir des légumes et des et
des fruits il y a des espaces qui sont
en plein air et des espaces Souss alors
effectivement aujourd'hui on serait plus
Souss euh il y a des tas de choses à
découvrir il y a des produits à acheter
et notamment des produits qui arrivent
d'autres fermes il y a des saucissons
des
pâtées des terines toutes sortes de
choses à découvrir en plus de ce que
l'on a cueilli dans cette ferme du Clos
d'quani donc d'quani a c'est Nom la
Bretèche et la dernière ferme dont vous
voulez parler celle-là on la connaît sur
TVfil c'est la ferme de viltin à jou en
Josas voà c'est ça alors la ferme de
Vilin a cette particularité euh qu'on
peut cueillir acheter mais il y a le
circuit du lait alors c'est un circuit
pédagogique on découvre sur une espèce
de mézanine les petits veau et puis en
même temps la traite des vaches qui a
lieu tous les jours entre 16h30 et 18h30
et donc pour les enfants comme on le
voit à l'image grand aussi parce que
c'est une grand grande ferme oui oui oui
c'est immense et les enfants adorent
découvrir tout ça et on peut acheter
bien sûr les produits de la ferme parce
que c'est c'est également l'idée de de
ce type de ferme c'est qu'on peut
acheter les produits sur place et on
peut aussi assister à la traite la
traite entre c'est ce que je disais
15h30 17h30 voilà tout à fait là c'est
pour la partie cuillette et il y a la
partie boutique que vous avez aussi don
vous avez un pe peu parler là c'est plus
pour ce ce weekend c'est ça c'est là où
on va aller ce
weekendir ce weekend et par contre on va
se rendre dans les dans les boutiques
gourmandes et on va commencer à la ferme
de Coubertin à saint-réis les chevau
maisou alors la ferme de de Coubertin
elle est spécialisée donc sur les
produits laitiers on peut y acheter de
de merveilleux yaourt de la crème
fraîche du lait cru et des fromages plus
particulièrement des fromages de chèvr
euh ils ont été d'ailleurs primés hein
pour tous ces fromages euh donc on y va
le weekend on découvre tout ça puis on
voit aussi les les animaux parce que
l'idée quand on va acheter des produits
dans une ferme avec les enfants c'est
qu'on voit les animaux les petits
chevreuxx les petites chèvres euh les
lapins les cochons et donc une belle
après-midi ou matinée en perspective
voilà et il y a aussi une traite euh des
vaches qui a lieu vers 16h30 et la prêre
des chèvres vers 18h15 voilà pour ceux
qui vouz c'est la ferme de Coubertin à
Saint-Rémy les Chevreuse allez la ferme
de Grignon avec une initiative dont on a
pas mal parlé sur TVfil et qui est très
intéressante c'est le drive laitier àval
oui hein le drive c'est tout à fait à la
mode partout on fait on fait ses courses
voilà celui-là est laitier puisque c'est
sa spécialité effectivement euh vous
pouvez donc commander en ligne et aller
chercher vos produits le vendredi euh à
la à la ferme de tiverval qui est
effectivement aussi spécialisé dans les
dans les produits laitiers et euh qui
euh qui propose des des produits qui
soient produits durables et produits bio
donc tout tout ce qu'on aime en ce
moment hein on est vraiment sur la
nature le retour aux sources c'est pour
ça que je vous ai proposé un peu un peu
tout ça aujourd'hui et à cette dans
cette ferme là c'est sa spécialité et
donc on récupère ses produits laitier le
vendredi alors que je vous dis 16h 20h
non c'est moi qui donne les horaires
d'AC je suis la spécialiste des
spécialiste desires t un peu à les
mélanger sans les regarder c'est normal
j'ai une fiche aussi c'est facile pour
moi donc c'est 16h à 20h le vendredi
pour le drave laitier ça se passe du
côté de tiverval Grignon la boutique de
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet ça
c'est aussi très connu oui alors non
seulement on peut visiter La Bergerie
Nationale parce que c'est très connu
c'est dans un lieu super agréable à côté
du château mais en plus dans cette
Bergerie Nationale il y a une boutique
gourmande euh donc dans cette boutiques
gourmande c'est extrêmement varié non
seulement il y a les produits de la
bergerie mais il y a des produits qui
arrivent euh d'autres boutiques
françaises avec toutes les spécialités
que la France peut peut comporter ça va
de la conserve au potage en passant par
les jus de fruits les œufs enfin bref
j'en pas c'est des meilleurs mais vous
avez aussi une spécialité c'est que vous
avez des produits faits en laine des
moutons de la Bergerie Nationale des
pulls des tas mininos le fameux merinos
donc ça c'est quand même extraordinaire
de se dire qu'on a un pull avec de la
laine de mérinos de la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet c'est pas rien
et vousêtes pas vous n'avez pas mis
votre joli pull non il faisait quand
même un peu chaud
ch allez on finit avec la la boutique du
Potager du Roi à versaill alors là
évidemment le Potager du Roi oui c'est
ça c'est les légumes anciens c'est ce
que j'allais dire si vous me dites si
vous dites tout ce que j'ai à dire j'ai
rien à dire in ah là là là là cette
Catherine mais elle connaî tout elle
aime tout c'est pour ça euh donc le le
le Potager du Roi à versaill bah on le
connaît parce qu'effectivement c'est
historique c'est la quintini jardinier
en chef de de Louis XIV qui l'a fondé
mais il a aussi sa boutique gourmande
donc on découvre tout un tas de de
légumes anciens légumes qui sont donc
découverts fabriqués sur place et puis
effectivement il y a d'autres produits
qu'on peut acheter hein au Potager du
Roi et on peut faire la visite avant
acheter les produits ensuite et c'est et
c'est des c'est pas des légumes
historiques hein des légumes anciens
mais c'est comme des légumes anciens
c'est on redécou goû et qu'on a pas
l'habitude comme les Panis par exemple
c'est des légumes qu'on dont on a pas
l'habitude de forcément consommer tous
les jours merci syie pour ces idées
sorti on vous retrouve dans 15 jours
pour une nouvelle chronique ça merci à
vous allez ce weekend une autre activité
cette fois on va aller du côté
d'élancour avec la visite des serer
municipal sera cela va avoir lieu toute
la journée Mathieu Bidan s'est rendu sur
place l'occasion d'en savoir plus sur le
travail des jardiniers de la ville à H
encour les trois fleurs qui s'affichent
sur les panneaux de la ville ne doivent
rien au hasard dans les seres
municipales André le responsable de la
production s'active avant le rush du
printempsi mon job c'est surtout de
rester dans pratiquement sur les serres
et tout ce qui fait déco sur la ville
tout ce qui est décoration intérieure
floral pour toutes les manifestations
culturelles sportives rampotage
repiquage ou mise en place des
jardinières et des massifs dans la ville
ce sont les jardiniers qui donnent de la
couleur dans les rues c'est un petit peu
le phénomène de mode on a vu que bon il
y avait beaucoup de gens l'année
dernière qui préféra le rose un petit
peu le blanc donc on s'est dit cette
année on va essayer le rose blanc puis
l'année prochaine on choisira un are
colori quoi on prend un petit peu la
température avec les portes ouvertes en
2013 la commune a consacré 87000 € à son
fleurissement HERV Bernet le responsable
a vu la ville changer depuis son arrivée
il y avait quasiment rien ici hein B on
arrivait tout ça on arrivit là
maintenant bon ben c'est c'est bien quoi
je veux dire c'est sympa bon puis même
même pour la ville quoi je veux dire
c'est ville fleoris c'est quand même
plus agréable enfin je pense enfin
j'espère pour tous les amateurs de
belles plantes les seres s'ouvre au
public ce samedi 26 avril un moment de
partage qui permet aux jardiniers de
préparer les prochaines saisons c'est
important d'échanger avec les gens qui
sont sur la commune parce que bon ils se
rendent pas compte forcément du travail
que ça représente aussi à l'intérieur
ils voit sur la ville comment s'est
positionné mais derrière tout ça il y a
il y a un travail quand même qui est
assez important sur l'année plus de 400
curieux s'était bousculé les années
précédentes pour recevoir les conseils
avisés des jardiniers ouverture des
portes à
9h et on poursuit ce 78 weekend avec un
concert donné samedi soir à la meurise
de trappe par l'association traap star
en plateau le président de l'association
baudé c'est votre nom d'artiste euh une
scène qui va réunir une vingtaine
d'artistes qui sont tous t rappeur et
tous issus de trappe voilà
expliquez-nous ça en fait on a eu un
projet à l'époque il y a 2 ans avec un
collègue qui s'appelle dasmi on a on a
réuni tous les artistes de traap pour
créer justement un CD une fois qu' est
sorti on s'est dit pourquoi pas faire un
concert et puis le concert a lieu concer
à lieu demain d'accord alors je vais
peut-être montrer le le CD effectivement
ça c'est le CD qui qui est paru il y a
il y a 2
ans an il y a un an voilà et donc ce
sonont les artistes qui seront présents
parmi les les artistes il y a mass
notamment m mas Miss Kelly il y a green
Canardo il y aura chabodo et plein
d'autres artistes d'acord une vingtaine
d'artistes en tout d'artistes euh parmi
ceux qui ont participé à cette à ce CD
il y a La Fouine notamment et la fine
sera pas sera pas présent parce que il
est un peu occupé en ce moment ouais bon
sinon il serait venu ouais pourquoi
réuni que des artistes de trappp parce
que je me suis dit qu'à traape il y a
quand même beaucoup d'artistes c'est
issu c'est c'est quand même un nid
d'artiste traap notamment avec diamè
Debous au Marcille puis les chanteurs
comme la fouill canardau et puis je me
suis dit bah autant les réunir sur la
même compine mais je présume que tous
ces artistes se connaissaient quand même
quand on fait la même type de musique en
principe on se on fréquente que ce soit
même pas pour la musique du moment où
ils habitent à trappe ils se connaissent
un peu tousna et comment vous expliquez
justement qu'il a autant d'artistes
rappeurs à Trapp franchement je sais pas
du tout pourquoi la la ville est
porteuse comme ça de ce mouvement je
sais pas du tout c'est peut-être un
effet de mode voilà lui il a sorti ça
pourquoi pas moi et vous-même alors
votre parcours moi-même ah VO là c'est
un autre sujet le par mon parcours
j'étais le premier producteur à enfin
manager à La Fouine
euh il m'a cité dans son livre justement
et voilà à partir de là je me suis mis
un peu en retrait après ça et là je suis
revenu avec je suis revenu dans la
musique d'accord donc on a dit ce qui a
été qui a été fait il y a il y a une
année ce ce concert qui aura lieu samedi
soir euh pourquoi pourquoi ce label
parce que finalement vous avez pas de
distributeur c'est un qu ch vous fait
vraiment par par vousême et pourquoi ce
travail pourquoi ce bah on a voulu faire
ça pour faire connaître un peu à c'est
un téléchargement légal sur iTunes donc
on on a mis ça avec les réseaux sociaux
un peu de publicité pour voir ce que la
ville peut sait faire sur au niveau rap
et puis elle est assez connue aussi sur
T ça et vous m'avez dit on n' pas eu
troué de distributeur c'est parce que
c'est compliqué de trouver des
distributeurs pour la musique rap en
particulier ou parce que c'est
globalement difficile de trouver des
distributeur c'est déjà difficile en
général de trouver un un distributeur
pour la musique rap et puis surtout que
pour celui-là pour cet album là c'est
qu'il y a plein de d'artistes différents
certains ont déjà signé donc pour avoir
les droits et tout ça donc parce qu'il y
a quand même des artistes connu heard la
f misselly c'est quand même des gens qui
ont déjà des petits noms dans le milieu
voilà c'est ça du coup on a préféré
faire ça en en ind puis on a eu les
accords par contre et puis on a lancé ça
d'accord donc ce sera un CD qu'on peut
retrouver que vous pouvez retrouver sur
iTunes et le soir de du concert demain
samedi soir euh et alors il faut savoir
aussi que les fonds du concert seront
euh iront à votre association et le but
c'est de financer un studio
d'enregistrement parce qu'il y en a il y
a pas assez il y a aucun studio
d'enregistrement à trappe ah même à la
musique d'école et deedans non c'est des
studios de répète c'est pas des studio
d'enregistrement d' ouais donc voilà on
voudrait créer justement un studio
d'enregistrement à trrappe par vu qu'il
y a beaucoup d'artistes comment ça se
passe concrètement pour les artistes
just bah ils sont obligés de se déplacer
sur Paris euh voilà sur Paris autour de
Paris parce que sur les yelines il y a
pas de studio puis ma connaissance je
sais pas sur trap en tout cas il y en a
pas d'accord mais il faut beaucoup de
fond hein pour faut beaucoup de fond
ouais ben c'est un début c'est un début
on a essayé de demander quelques
subventions aussi puis on attend donc
l'entrée du concert est à combien c'est
7 € l'entrée du concert et 10 € avec le
CD d'accord donc le le label c'est une
première pour le label trapstar ça veut
dire que ça pourrait amener d'autres
concerts d'autres CD d'autres mix
surtout d'autres concerts on essayie de
faire ça un peu dans tout le
78 donc euh avis au au maires de des
alentours s'ils sont prêts à nous
accueillir on vient avec un plateau
aussi important que ça artist parce que
là c'est quand même un gros plateau
ouais c'est un gros plateau il y a une
vingtaine d'artistes donc euh et vous
avez déjà essayé de contacter des
d'autres mairés d'autres municipalités
pas encore mais ça va se faire ouais
ouais ça va se faire vous attendez
peut-être de voir le ce que va donner
con d'accord donc euh concert samedi
soir premier concert du de l'association
trap star euh ce sera donc samedi à la
merurise de trap samedi à partir de de
20h avec notamment tête affiche mas ou
encore Canardo ou Miss Miss Kelly euh
voilà et puis les fonds seront euh
seront reversés à l'association pour
permettre le financement d'un studio
d'enregistrement euh je profite de votre
venue en plateau bé pour vous poser une
question sur l'actualité du moment c'est
le rappeur r le rappeur a été placé en
détention provisoire jeudi après-midi il
avait il a été mis en examen pour
violence volontaire en réunion avec
préméditation après la baguarre à
laquelle il a participé dans une
boutique distribuant les vêtements de la
marque de son rival Booba euh vous en
pensez quoi euh est-ce que ça ça peut
ternir l'image du rap ou c'est un juste
un phénomène un ép ou je pense que ça a
été loin quand même un peu d'arriver
jusqu'à là
mais ça aurait ça serait resté en clash
au niveau musical entre eux il y aurait
pas de souci mais venir à là franchement
ça a été un peu loin c'est ce que je
pense après ouais donc pas de caution
pas de caution pas du tout merci
beaucoup bé d'être ven sur le plateau de
téléfil nous parlerit surtout du du
concert de samedi soir à la merurise de
trappe allez on va pour poursivre ce C
weekend avec les sorties cinées de ce
mercredi et les avis des spectateurs
surtout c'est super et c'est très génial
j'ai trouvé ça très mignon très bien
fait très agréable des beaux enfin une
belle réalisation des beaux personnages
et puis une moralité enfin très sympa
c'était comment mon P bien c'était bien
j'ai pas trop aimé le style c'est très
moyen très moyen je peux pas dire autre
chose ça m'a pas j'ai pas accroché c'est
pitoyable voilà c'est une catastrophe
c'est bourré de cliché c'est un des
pires films que j'ai vu cette année j'ai
failli partir au bout de 20 minutes j'ai
pas j'ai pas trouvé l'histoire
extraordinaire heureusement qu'il y
avait clus dans le film c'est excellent
oui c'est excellent c'est un polar à
l'ancienne c'est bien ça m'a fait penser
au film avec nouventura j'ai adoré j'ai
j'ai bien aimé mais je préférais la
version française que américaine c'est
un bon film d'action la fin on s'y
attend pas voilà c'est c'est bien c'est
distrayant c'est un très bon film et
puis il y a plein d'actions puis
voilà allez avant de nous quitter un
dernier coup d'œil sur les événements à
retenir pour ce weekend tout d'abord la
traditionnelle faite des fleurs et des
jardins cela va se passer à la ferme du
meanet à Montini le Bretonneux c'est la
11e édition organisée par le Lyon club
au profit de la lutte contre la cécité
et puis une autre animation cette
fois-ci à manie lesamo et l'association
des joyeux traité qui organise son
traditionnel thé dansant voilà cette
émission est maintenant terminée merci
d'avoir suivi bon weekend à
vous